so tired bill okay okay stop mom
you Ramon this century please honey we
thought you'd be home I postponed dinner
as long as I could
there's the dog watching me you know why
she's gone can you help me so one tell
me what is going on right now we have to
show you
[Music]
Jill why isn't she answering is there a
medical term for this condition behaving
like a dog is it the barking you figure
out a way to pick my kids up what are
the names your kids schools I don't know
[Music]
listen got a little situation she has no
lunch he's actually a grocery store
right down the street
she has no lunch she has no lunch dr.
linen well could you possibly come over
here and look at my wife she needs
comprehensive psychiatric care she's not
going to a mental institution we don't
have any food we're so hungry
this is a very bad time for me what is
going on with your wife I have to be at
work 18 hours a day
oh yeah
course fabulous
[Music]
maybe Jill's doing you a favor maybe
it's the life you're supposed to be
living this is the life that I'm
supposed to live this is this is what it
was all supposed to be this is part of
the big plan hey good evening sir
I'm gonna see your wife she is in the
basement little door on your right
bring it you toy
you
you